She was crowned in Westminster Abbey in June 1953,...
...but she became Queen on the 6th of February 1952, the day her father died.
A few years earlier, she'd made this statement of intent.
I declare before you all that my whole life, whether it be long or short,...
...shall be devoted to your service and to the service of our great imperial family,...
...to which we all belong.
That imperial family is long gone, but most British people will agree,...
...that seven decades later, her commitment to public service has been fulfilled.
Despite a life of obvious privilege, the Queen retains widespread popular support.
Last year, she lost her husband, the Duke of Edinburgh, after 73 years of marriage.
Few could help being moved by her mourning alone at his COVID limited funeral.
Her reign has spanned a period of huge change.
Britain relinquished its empire and grappled with reduced power and influence.
She has held weekly meetings with 14 prime ministers,...
...but has never committed herself to a known political opinion.
I mean she's the most charismatic, sort of photographed,...
...most famous woman in the world, but she's also very enigmatic.
We hardly know her, and I think being able to stay above politics,...
...but seen as relevant and respected has been really important.